so one of the astonishing facts from the
human genome project was that single
nucleotide variants occur approximately
one every 300 nucleotides so if you do
the math that means there are roughly 10
million single nucleotide variants in
the human genome and these variations
are one contributing factor to the
genetic diversity in humans
and so this opened up a whole new set of
questions so what is the intersection
between disease and genetic variants
what's the relationship between drug
metabolism and genetic variation is
there a cancer genome and does that
cancer genome change over time in in
between the the primary tumor and a
metastasis or a recurrence
how does the genome impact mental health
behavioral health
it had already been observed that some
diseases were more prevalent in certain
populations and so then questions about
what's the role of genetic variation in
ethnicity
and so over the years that followed the
completion of the human genome reference
sequence it became more and more clear
that we knew too little